[Musique]
soir les enfants bon port
nicolas et pimprenelle ont l'air très
sage
j'ai bien l'impression qu'ils sont déjà
couchés nounours méfiez-vous des eaux
dormantes
mon le joueur ne fait pas trop de bruit
pour ne pas les réveiller sommes nous à
grand
popo peu
[Musique]
votre avis mais non ils ne sont pas
couchés peau soir les enfants
approche toi de nous au
soir à dos plein de merveilles vous la
trouvez dans le placard de maman ou leur
creux de mercoeur il est plein de
merveilles
aucun qu'est ce que c'est un tchador
avec jam dessus du
hall à la quelle merveille un coquillage
qu'est ce que tu fais nous j'écoute
j'entends lammer
tient à toi
la mer
et ça encore coquille hommes et encore
un autre
elmer veut il est même note la dame
s'est trop gentil merci le plus qu'ils
ne pourraient coûter la mer ce tournage
et nous on n'écoutera pas mettre les
mâles et vienne et colas alors on lit
[Musique]
on se croirait à la mer quelle merveille
bonne nuit les petits
[Musique]
c'est un lieu
donné
anita prenait fait beau rêve petit frère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonne nuit les enfants
mais qu'a fait tu nounours j'écoute le
bruit de labeur repos quel gros
coquillage ce sont mes amis qui m'ont
donné ils sont très gentils auj
on n'y va pas trop à rod nounours ben et
nuit dom
[Musique]